the Battle of the Trident may have been
an important victory for the usurper but
it was the treachery and barbarism of
Tywin Lannister that sealed the fate of
the Targaryen dynasty my father King
Aerys had ever been a friend to the
Lions of the rock
Aerys graciously brought Tywin to court
making him the youngest hand of the king
in history he gave him power he gave him
respect he made it possible for Tywin to
restore House Lannister to glory Aries
and Tywin governed side by side for 20
prosperous years still when the usurper
called his banners in rebellion Tywin
Lannister ignored his Kings pleas for
help and stayed holed up in his
stronghold of Casterly Rock in time my
brother Prince Rhaegar was dead the
realm was in turmoil and the usurpers
forces were said to be writing for
King's Landing what a glorious sight it
must have been when a force of 10,000
Lannister men showed up at the gate of
the capital with Lord Tywin at their
head pledging support to his beleaguered
King Aerys opened the gates for his old
friend instead Lannister and his men
proceeded to plunder and destroy the
city that he had called home for decades
as the capital was ravaged and its
people terrorized Jaime Lannister son of
Lord Tywin proved every bit as
treacherous he killed my father the king
at the foot of the Iron Throne
the Lannisters entered the Red Keep and
Tywin ordered the deaths of the rest of
the royal family
it is said princess Ramos was found
cowering under her father's bed and put
to the sword she was only a child
as for Rhaegar widow Elia she was forced
to watch as Lannister thugs dashed her
baby son's head against a wall before
being raped and murdered herself as I
was the heir to my Father's throne I had
been spirited away to Dragonstone with
my mother Queen rhaella who was with
child as a raging summer storm battered
the island fortress and destroyed the
Targaryen fleet as it lay at anchor my
sister Daenerys was born my mother the
Queen died giving birth
now some 17 years later the rightful
king still lives in exile but a day of
reckoning is coming I will sail west as
Aegon the dragon did centuries before I
will take back my Father's throne
with blood and Fire and I will punish
the treacherous dogs who sought to
destroy my family
and the people shall rejoice